[Musique]
nous avons un observateur direct sur ce
qui se passe dans l'anomalie de west
view
à votre avis c'est quoi ça c'est une
réalité alternative un voyage dans le
temps
c'est une sitcom avec deux avengers
c'est une première théorie au jeu c'est
le tablier et probablement excessif mais
sache que je fais de mon mieux pour
m'intégrer
bonjour très cher à léger malaise
la vie passe tellement vite dans notre
petite ville
il y a
un truc qui cloche ici
alors on en était
[Musique]
enfin
la commande était commencée
il ya à l'extérieur de west view
[Musique]
oui j'ai du mal à comprendre ce qui se
passe c'est probablement ce genre de mal
du lundi c'était pas vrai
ces frais briefé oui mon ange et vous
pleurez pas je m'applique à 20
[Musique]